bon bah voilà 2020 s'est terminée quelle
année mais amicale année quelle année
bien pourri web non mais sérieusement ce
n'était pas l'année la plus nas qu'on
n'ait jamais eu ça a commencé en janvier
avec les incendies en australie 18
millions d'hectares brûlés un milliard
d'animaux tués
vous les avez vu les images du petit
koala et bam ça continue le breakbeat
après des mois et des mois de
tergiversations le divorce puis uk a
lieu le 31 janvier
on passe sur février alors là le summum
confinement cosider tout un toit vous
connaissez la musique
tout le monde reste chez soi les connu
dégringole le chômage explose +22 6% en
avril chez les chômeurs de catégorie a
les entreprises qui ferment leurs
rideaux l'activité est ralentie
d'environ 30% selon les estimations du
ministère de l'économie
et si pendant quelques semaines d'été on
a eu l'espoir de retrouver une vie à peu
près normale
la deuxième vague lanouaille et assouvir
second confinement pull léger certes
mais qui fait quand même mal à
l'économie
au total 2020 aurait vu le pib français
chuté de près de 10%
cerise sur le gâteau le plan de relance
européen censé relancer toute l'union
européenne s'est retrouvé bloqué par le
veto de la hongrie et la pologne
reste maintenant à savoir ce que nous
réservera 2021
un vaccin une économie qui redémarre ou
alors une troisième vague un nouveau
confinement dans le tiroir cash
n'évitera toute prévision on préfère
vous laisser regarder dans la boule de
cristal de viviers de la marche
nous on dira juste que dans ses
prévisions de l'année dernière locaux
vides pas même lui il n'avait pas vu
venir
[Musique]